Transcriber: Mira Osama
المدقّق: Manal Abed Al Rahman
[التجربة]
[فعالية منظمة بشكل مستقل]
(تصفيق)
لا أعلم ماذا أقول.
حرفياً، لقد انهوا الموضوع.
كيف أحوالكم؟ في البداية، أحب أن أقول
إنني سعيد جدًا أن الفريق
قد اختارني لأن أكون هنا،
وما شاء اللّه، هناك مجموعة عظيمة
حضرت اليوم وتحدثت قبلي.
لا أظن أنني سأضيف
أكثر مما قيل،
لكن سأحاول إن شاء اللّه
أن أنقل لكم شيء مختلف
وهي الخبرة العملية.
التحدي الحقيقي أن يحاول الشخص
تلخيص عمل طال لمدة 15 سنة في 15 دقيقة،
ولكن اللّه المستعان.
مبدأيًا...
من خلال متابعتي لوسائل التواصل
ووجودي وسط الشباب
وسماع أفكار الشباب باستمرار،
أجد أن النجاح له قوالب محددة
ملخصة في أشياء معينة
تشتت الشباب عن المففهوم الأكبر والموضوعي.
يعني الفكرة، النجاح ليس ملخصًا
في أن يكون دخلك مليون جنيه أو أربعة ملايين
أو يكون عندك عدد معين من الشهادات
أو أن تكون ناجحًا في مستقبلك المهني.
مجرد امتلاكك للأفكار
أو أن تمتلك العقلية للاستيقاظ وأنت سعيد
وراضي بما هو متاح أمامك،
هذا في حد ذاته نجاح.
يجب أن نتفق على ذلك.
الإنسان، في الأصل،
يجب أن يكون سعيدًا،
إنسان منتج وسعيد،
إنسان مفيد لغيره من الناس،
مهتم بالدائرة القريبة منه.
هذا هو النجاح،
هذا هو المتوازن.
أما فكرة توجيه العقل لجهة واحدة فقط،
أنه يجب عليّ تجميع أكبر قدر من المال،
أن المال هو السعادة، أن المال هو كل شيء،
نعم، المال يجعل الحياة أسهل،
يعطيك الاختيارات،
المال يجعلك حرًا في بعض المواقف
ويعطيك حرية الأختيار،
أما السعادة، فهو شيء داخلي.
السعادة تكون في الرضا والقناعة.
السعادة شيء تقوم أنت بتنظيم أفكارك عليها،
لأنه من الممكن أن يكون
دخلك مليون جنيهًا أو ما يزيد
ولكن لست سعيدًا.
لم تتعلم كيف تكون سعيدًا.
ولكي تتعلم كيف تكون سعيدًا...
يجب أن تنسق أفكارك،
وأن تكون سعيدًا ودخلك ألف جنيه في الشهر،
كي تكون سعيدًا عندما يتحول لمليون.
لأن المال مجرد أداة
نستخدمها لجعل الحياة أفضل.
حسنًا، لندخل في صلب الموضوع،
الحظ.
إذا أخبرت أحدًا أن هذا الشخص ناجح،
أن هذا الشخص تم تعيينه في وظيفة،
أو أن الآخر رجل أعمال إلخ...
ماذا سيُقال؟ إنه محظوظ
هل هذا الكلام صحيح أم خاطئ؟ حاظئ؟
-لا
-بلا، إنه الحظ، هل أكذب؟
إنه الحظ، ولكن هناك أمرٌ ما:
الحظ يأتي لكل الناس.
يمر علينا الحظ والفرص كل يوم، كل يوم!
كل يوم تمر علينا آلاف الفرص،
ومن الحظوظ مالا يمكن تخيله.
ولكن من الذي يرى هذه الفرص؟
من هو مستعد لها؟
وكيف أكون مستعدًا للفرصة؟
ما يجعلني مستعدًا للفرصة هو...
أن يكون إدراكي للأمور مختلفًا عن غيري.
بمعنى
أنه لا يمكننك الاكتفاء بفكرة
أنك طالبًا في الجامعة
وتنتظر التخرج لترى ما الذي ستفعله بعد ذلك.
الحياة العلمية، وجمع الشهادات،
والتفوق الدراسي، كل هذا جيد
ولكن هناك شيء مهم يجب أن تكون ملمًا به
وهي الحياة.
يجب أن تقوم بتجميع الخبرات من أرض الواقع.
نصيحتي لكل الشاب الصغير الذي مازال يدرس،
والخريج، ومن لازال في الثانوية العامة،
ومن لازال في الجامعة، هي أن يعمل.
اذهب واعمل، اذهب إلي السوق
لتري كيف هو الشارع وكيف هي الحياة.
حتى لو كنت طبيبًا،
ستستفيد إذا عملت في محل تجاري.
ستتعلم مهارات التواصل،
تتعلم مفهوم الإلتزام،
ستري الناس في الشوارع
وتفهم كيف هو الوضع العام،
وتمتلك تصور واقعي للحياة.
هذا أفضل من أن تكون معزولًا في البيئة
الآمنة في البيت وسط أهلك وأصحابك.
المشكلة أن الشبب في السن الصغير عنيدًا
جدًا ويعتقد أن لديه إجابات لجميع الأسئلة.
كل الأسئلة لديك إجاباتها!
ترافض الاستماع لأي توجيه من أي أحد،
ترافض الاستماع لأي شيء من أي أحد.
ولكن إذا فكرت وسألت
الأكبر منك بخمسة سنوات
عن رأيه في أسلوب تفكيره
وهو بسن 21 سنة،
سيقول: “لا أعلم كيف كنت أفكر.”
أنت الأن، انظر لنفسك
قبل خمسة سنوات، كيف كنت تفكر؟
سترى درجة العند والثقة بالنفس
التي كنت تملكها مرعبة.
ولكن كلما تتقدم بالعمر،
ترى أنه لايزال أمامك الكثير.
هناك الكثير لتتعلمه.
حتى الآن، لم نتحدث عن الموضوع
الذي جئنا من أجله
لكن هذا هو الكلام الذي أريد قوله.
أحببت أن أتحدث لأخوتي الصغار
وأن أنقل لهم التجارب قدر المستطاع،
ولكن هذه الأشياء ليست قوانين
فلكل شخص قصته المختلفة،
لا توجد قصة يمكن تعميمها علي الجميع،
لكل منا قصة يعيشها بشكل مختلف.
هناك قصص تُحكي لأول مرة،
لكن هنالك عوامل مشتركة في كل القصص،
وأولها أن الحظ يأتي لمن هو مستعد له،
والحظ ليس صدفة
إنما هو نصيب.
نصيبك هو حظك.
وكلما زاد مجهودك، زاد حظك في الدنيا.
هذا أولاً، أما ثانيًا...
الخسارة والفشل.
لنتحدث عن الخسارة والفشل.
أي إنسان له نصيب من الخسارة والفشل.
الخسارة أمر واقع.
ستخسر أحدًا تحبه
أو أحدًا عزيزًا عليك أو تفارق أحدًا تحبه.
ستخسر في مشروع، تفشل في مشروع تخرج،
ستفشل دراسيًا في شيء كنت تخطط له ولم ينجح.
فالخسارة والفشل أمر واقع
في حياة أنجح الناجحين.
لكن الفرق بين شخص وآخر
هو مفهومك للخسارة،
مفهومك للخسارة
وكيف تقرر التعامل معها.
إذا قررت النظر للأمام
والتعلم من أسباب الخسارة
أو نظرت للأمام
وركزت على ما تملكه في الحاضر،
الحاضر هو الذي سيضمن لك أن يكون الغد أفضل
وينسيك الخسارة التي تعرضت لها في الماضي.
لذلك لا توقف حياتك على موقف خسرت فيه.
لا توقف حياتك بسبب شيء تمنيته ولم يحدث.
أحيانًا يغلق اللّه بابًا ليفتح
بابًا أفضل تعبر منه،
وهذا عن تجربتي،
لقد جربت هذا الشيء آلاف المرات.
حدثت معي كثيرًا جدًا،
أشياء بنيت عليها كل أحلامي،
وأشياء خططت عليها حياتي
أشياء كانت تعد من نقاط الإرتكاز
في حياتي ومع ذلك، خسرتها.
وسبحان اللّه، كان صعب جدًا عليّ
أن أتحرك إلى الأمام، وأن أركز بما أمتلك،
وأن أنفذ ما أقوله لكم الآن.
ولكن الآن أستعجب
كيف كنت متعلقًا بهذا الأشياء؟
وهكذا، لنرى التالي.
هل يمكن أن نبدأ من الصفر؟
نعم، لم لا؟ وحتى لو لم يكن هنالك صفر،
ليس مطلوبًا منك في العشرينات
أو إن كنت لا تزال تدرس
أن تكون مُلمًا بإجابات كل الأسئلة.
هناك أسئلة كثيرة جدًا
وأنت لا تحتاج إجاباتها الآن
ما يجب أن تهتم به
هو أن تستغل ما هو متاح أمامك الآن.
تعامل مع الموضوع مثل....
هل تعرفون لعبة (PUBG)؟
بالطبع جميعكم تعرفونها،
في هذه اللعبة، كلنا نبدأ من مستوى واحد
من يتحرك أكثر، ويذهب، ويأتي،
هو الذي يجمع الأسلحة والمنتصر في اللعبة.
هكذا الحياة،  الموضوع ذاته.
جميعكم بدأتم في مستوي واحد:
جميعكم طلاب جامعيون، جميعكم تدرسون،
ومتاحٌ لكم الفرص نفسها.
ولكن من الذي سيتميز ويختلف عن الباقي؟
هو الذي يتحرك أكثر.
ولذلك فإجابة هذا السؤال هي السعي.
هناك طريق لن تعرف شكله نهايًا
إلا عندما تتحرك في داخله.
وبمجرد أن تأخذ خطوات،
سيتبين لك معالم الطريق.
هناك شيء أحب أن أنقله للناس
من خلال تجربتي الشخصية.
لن أستطيع البوح بما ننفذه الآن
لكنه عمل ضخم، الحمدللّه
إنه عملاق.
مؤسستنا أصبحت تضم 200 موظف.
وهذا ليس بفضل
عبقريتي أو ذكائي، حرفيًا يعني.
إنما هو رزق مقدر لمن معي.
و في الوقت ذاته،
السر الذي أقام هذه الشركة
هو أنه على المرء إذا امتلك مشروعه الخاص...
تعامل مع من يعملون معك
بكونهم بشر، وأن لهم أحلامًا و طموحصًا،
وأن لا تستغل أحدًا إذا وجدته متحمسًا،
ويريد العمل، ومجتهدًا،
فبقدر عطائك للعاملين معك،
تجد اللّه ييسر لك السبل
ويفتح لك أبوابًا،
ويجعل حظوظك أفضل بمليون مرة.
ما أقصده هو أن أكثر ما أحدث
فارقًا في رحلتي
وما جعل العمل بهذا الحجم
هو العطاء،
فكرة أن تكون خيرًا لمن حولك،
أنك حقًا مهتم بمن حولك،
ستجد أن الناس تظهر أحسن ما في أنفسهم،
فالعطاء لا ينقص مما عندك أبدًا أبدًا،
إنما يبنيه.
وفعلًا، كل قانون من القوانين الإلهيه
المتعلقة بتعمير الأرض،
أو التعاون مع الغير، أو الزراعة
ولا تستعجل الحصاد،
تجد الثمار غريبة و المردود هائل.
أتمنى يكون هذا الكلام الغريب الغير مترابط
قادر على توصيل أي رسالة.
يعلم اللّه أنني أحبكم،
وأنني لم آتي للأستعراض أو الشهرة
ولكنني محتسب النية للّه
وأن أحاول توصيل الكلام الذي يفرق مع الناس
والشباب الموجود ويجعل حياتهم أحسن.
أراكم على خير.